hello grammarians all right today i want
to start talking about conjunctions and
conjunctions are this part of speech
that has a very particular function in
english and what it does conjunctions
unite words phrases and clauses let me
let me show you an example so if you
want to talk about two things you could
say you could say peanut butter and
jelly
or if we're going to paraphrase eddie
izzard i might offer you the choice of
cake or death
you could also describe something as
being sad but true and these three are
the most commonly used conjunctions
because i would be remiss if i didn't
mention the the seminal
conjunction song that got me into the
grammar game in the first place
conjunction junction uh which i think
was written by jack sheldon or performed
by jack sheldon in like
1973. schoolhouse rock it's great look
it up
but what i'm going to talk about today
is a mnemonic or a memory aid called
fanboys you may have heard this before
fanboys
and this is how we remember the
coordinating conjunctions and you don't
need to worry about the name
coordinating conjunctions we'll get to
that later um for now just remember
fanboys
and so
fanboys
we'll go through how each one of these
are used over the next screen follow me
downstairs
so we've got for and nor but or yet and
so
and each of them have a different basic
function so let's let's review them
4 has this connotation
you can use it the way you would use a
word like since or because
as in
i do not eat buttons for they are not
food you can see i'm combining these
these two little sentences um using the
word for
we're using this this four to explain my
reasoning i do not eat buttons because
they are not food and four is a simpler
way to express that
the conjunction and
very elemental very important
conjunction combines one thing with
another
as in
the kangaroo robbed the bank and torched
the saloon rather a criminal kangaroo
and you can see we're using and to
combine these two ideas
right we're saying this thing happened
this thing also happened they happened
together
nor is similar to and but we use it to
combine untrue things we use it to
express negation so if i were going to
talk about an angry tree spirit for
example just to pull an example out of a
hat
i could say
she won't leave her tree nor will she
speak with humans
we use but to express exceptions as in
we used every building material but
chewing gum
right chewing gum is the exception to
every building material
we use or as a conjunction to choose
between options
as in would you rather have a pet bear
or a pet giraffe
we ask the hard questions in khan
academy yet is kind of like butt
except that we use it to
express unexpected things so i'm just
going to write to the contrary
as if i were sherlock holmes hollering
at a confused watson and to the contrary
my good man watson this is how we use
yet i'll show you
i want to leave yet i cannot so it sets
up this kind of push and pull dynamic in
a sentence is what yet does
we set the expectation i want to leave
and yet here's the unexpected what i'd
say an ironic part yet i cannot i want
to leave
but unfortunately or but unexpectedly
when you would say but unexpectedly just
use yet
and finally the last part of fanboys so
shows consequences
dougal was allergic to sheep so he
skipped the wool festival
right so
so we're trying to set up that as a
consequence of the first clause dougal
being allergic to sheep the thing that
follows is because of that he decided to
skip the wool festival
this is fanboys for and nor but or yet
so these are all covered in the
exercises you can learn anything david
out